[Music]
Swifties the name you're looking at the
next lead dog for the arctic blast
delivery service you're about to see the
magic show in 3 and the 2 and the 1 and
shoo swifty
I think I'm pouring a pill we uphill
swifty always dreamed of being the
world's greatest sled dog you are not a
dog you are a small arctic fox and today
you can't fight your metabolism I can
will that dream is about to take off
swifty hey swifty
please deliver this package for me
alright go are you sure about this I've
been waiting for this moment we round up
the bad guys bada bing bada boom justice
served
how about you something very bad is
going on in the Arctic jeremy renner we
got to stop Heidi Klum James Franco Viva
the resistance Jim please surprise
Omar sighs mainly michael madsen arctic
straw Laurie hold what do we got here
with Angelica Houston is my number one
stop and Alec Baldwin oh no we're gonna
be late any second
are you crazy
I am freaking out man what's good
possibly go wrong
we could become a Fox popsicle arctic
dogs yes ah that smell like the planet
made a poopy
[Music]